eine judo trainer haben gesagt du musst
mal pause machen weniger ist mehr
manchmal und ich habe gesagt nein ich
will mehr und mehr
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport report dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast unser olympia
bronzemedaillengewinner korporal schami
überrascht wie herzlich willkommen
es ist ein unglaublicher erfolg für dich
gewesen dass die medaille mitgenommen
hast du schon realisiert was da in den
letzten tagen passiert ist und das alles
auf dich zugekommen ist ja nach dem
empfang in wien es waren sehr viele
leute da und da habe ich langsam
realisiert was ich so in tokio erreicht
habe was sagst du jetzt denn nach ein
paar tagen schon drüber hinweg schlafen
wie ist die gefühlslage was du dort
alles erlebt hast ja jetzt langsam habe
ich schon realisiert
gefühlslage
ist sehr gut ich bin jetzt extrem
motivierter und
mein selbstvertrauen ist umso stärker
ist und ich werde weiter hart arbeiten
für noch größere folgen wir haben das im
vorgespräch schon gesprochen hast du
gesagt du bist jetzt voll motiviert ich
kenne das von meinen erfolgen wo ich
nachher mal nichts vom wasser sehen
wollte und doch überhaupt kein training
gesehen wollte bei dir ist das anders
nach dieser bronzemedaille was hast du
jetzt vor ja ich freue mich schon jetzt
von größeren erfolgen wie zum beispiel
in paris gold und so es ist noch ein
bisschen zeit dahin und ich muss noch
viel an sich arbeiten ich weiß was mir
noch fehlt und meine trainer genauso und
dass ich an ihm machen aber du sagst
tarif goldmedaille als großes ziel bis
dorthin gibt aber natürlich noch ganz
viele andere
wettkämpfe weltcups grand slams
europameisterschaften
weltmeisterschaften foto aufzeigen
kannst aber lasst uns noch kurz in tokio
bleiben ja du hast dich ganz knapp
qualifiziert hat doch vorher gesagt dass
er eigentlich am limit und dann dort
dieses ergebnis abzuliefern was war
jetzt das geheimnis
ja ich habe
verschiedene
grand slams em wm und so weiter top
leute geschlagen vom weltmeister zum
vize olympiasieger als mögliche
es hat leider immer der tag gefällt wo
ich sie an einem tag schlagen und das
ist mir jetzt bei den spielen
aufgegangen ich habe mich genau
qualifiziert ja das stimmt aber es
hat immer gesagt er da gefällt dass ich
richtig punkte bei den turnieren und was
war dieses mal anders dieses mal ja ich
habe mich sehr gut eingestellt gegen in
einzel- und gegner
mir war es egal ob dabei ist die nummer
eins der welt ist oder die nummer 30 ich
habe gewusst olympia ist etwas anderes
die karten werden neu gemischt und es
gab so viele überraschungen davor vor
dem spiel ich kenne auch bei sportler
die knapp qualifiziert waren und dann
olympiasieger wurden deshalb
gegner studiert was sind sie ein
schwächen was ich meine stärken die
übereinstimmt um das beste versucht zu
machen und an dem tag hat sehr gut
geklappt ja bis auf semifinale aber ich
werde weiter hart daran arbeiten das ist
beim nächsten mal fälle verläuft ich
glaube weil bei diesem fast perfekten
run bis hin zur medaille da kann man
auch das semifinal als sportler selbst
natürlich ist wahrscheinlich bitter wenn
man im finale möchte und auch um die
goldmedaille kämpfen möchte aber ich
denke trotzdem dass er zufrieden bist du
mit deiner gesamtleistung oder ja extrem
aber im ersten moment
semifinale wenn man verliert ist sehr
hart weil 20 minuten später kämpfe um
bronze und man muss sich dann wieder
finde man muss dann wieder die energie
herr holen und das war wirklich sehr
sehr schwer aber dank meiner trainer und
mein älterer bruder war mit dabei und
hat gesagt es ist olympia da ist der
brawn so holst oder die golden hair
holst mit der liste modelle und verpasst
die chance nicht und dann habe ich mich
wieder von vorne motiviert fokussiert
bin ich dann in gstaad für uns habe das
ding nach hause geholt und wie auch noch
das ist angesprochen dass man ganz wenig
zeit die rund 20 minuten zwischen
ziemlich finalkampf und dann dem kampf
und platz drei
vielleicht ist es so schwer ist es dass
man sich da wirklich auch mental dann
fokussiert im endeffekt wenn der kampf
um platz drei verloren geht dann ist man
am geteilten fünften platz und geht ohne
medaille nach hause und dann schaut die
welt ganz anders aus wie wichtig sind
diese paar minuten zwischen diesen
entscheidenden kämpfen sehr wichtig
jetzt bei den olympischen spielen ist
die mentale stärke sehr entscheidend
derjenigen der mental stark ist und ist
sehr gut eingestellt ist das war ich an
den tag denken da vielleicht an dem tag
olympiasieger werden alle anderen gegen
hat zum beispiel um prozent dominik
ressel ist vize europameister hat
mehrere grand slams gewonnen ist nur
zehn der welt hatte trotzdem und sogar
ein bisschen druck weil ich trotzdem
nicht der favorit bin deswegen haben
gedacht ja ich muss jetzt nicht wieder
von vorne motivieren und das beste
daraus machen wenn man fünf nach hause
fliegt ist halt richtig hat natürlich
auch eine top leistung also irgendwo
einen fünften spieler wollen jetzt aber
aus seiner position ist natürlich auch
da eine schwierige ausgangslage war das
vielleicht auch leichter da für dich
dass du sozusagen in der
außenseiterrolle warst vielleicht auch
sogar im gesamten turnierverlauf weil
keiner sich wirklich um zettel hatte
dass du da jetzt so weit kommt ist das
etwas was dir auch besser liegt ja auf
jeden fall
genau das in meiner meinung war das ist
auch das entscheidendste dass ich nicht
der top-favorit war
alle gegner haben gewusst dass ich gute
leute geschlagen habe ich war gern
außenseite der nicht die guten leute
geschlagen ich habe sehr gute leute
geschlagen sie selbst teams im finale
habe ich davor zweimal schon geschlagen
und japaner und alle möglichen und
deswegen hatten die druck und haben
gewusst dass ich mental stark bin und
die hatten einfach mehr druck als ich
und ich habe gar kein programm meine
trainer hat zu mir am selben tag in der
früh gesagt haben genießt am tag heute
solche tage wirst du nicht oft in der im
leben bekommen und versucht mich nicht
unter druck zu setzen du kannst es heute
schaffen wenn du es willst und ja und
dann ist es selbstverständlich dass
seine trainerin angesprochen yvonne
bönisch war selber olympiasiegerin für
deutschland 2014
nationaltrainerin in österreich wie
wichtig was sie für diesen erfolgreichen
anteil spielt sie sozusagen an dieser
medaille yvonne bönisch ist seit heuer
erst
als cheftrainerin österreich ja
wir verstehen uns sehr gut und wir haben
sehr hart gearbeitet im taktischen
bereich im technischen bereich ja und am
ende hat sich ausgezahlt dass selbst
beim ersten turnier top 6 und rest der
welt masters
wurde siebter das war ein sehr großer
erfolg für mich auch dort gute punkte
geholt für die olympia-quali danach
eineinhalb monate später konnte ich die
silbermedaille erkämpfen beim grand slam
in tiflis genau und dann ging es los 1
von 3 und dann mit em wm und olympia
habe ich leider ging das ski verloren
gehen der mich jetzt in der 2 unsere
ohren habe und im wm bin ich ebenso im
achtelfinale ausgeschieden ich war sehr
enttäuscht von meiner leistung heute ich
habe wirklich sehr sehr hart darauf
vorbereitet und
ja ich hab paar tage gebraucht dass ich
wieder ich selbst finde und wohnen hat
gesagt ja bruders aus es ist olympia
olympia etwas ganz besonderes das kannst
du nicht mit wm vergleichen schade dass
du jetzt
alles gibst jedes einzelne detail dort
ist und das irgendwie eine medaille holt
und dann ja wir verstehen uns sehr gut
und ich bin sehr dankbar dass sie ein
head coach ist ja und da scheint der
früchte die zusammenarbeit auch die
sportlichen erfolge zeigen ist aber auch
seine einstellung und und wie du jetzt
sofort motiviert an die nächsten
aufgaben gehst du hast jetzt vorher auch
angesprochen wie wichtig die taktische
vorbereitung ist auf die jeweiligen
gegner top leute die man wahrscheinlich
nur mit dieser taktischen vorbereitung
auch schlagen kann hast du da jetzt
etwas anders gemacht als bei den
wettkämpfen davor in der taktischen
vorbereitung ja ich habe mit meinen
jünger wurde wartet wir haben fast jeden
tag
versucht immer
neue gegner zu analysieren und papa
gegen hat sie wirklich lange gedauert da
sind wir schon wochen daran gesetzt
haben da gedacht was ist denn wenn das
passiert was ist wenn das passiert und
was ist wenn das nicht klappt und hin
und her wenn das wirklich sehr sehr
genau genommen und für ihn bin ich
extrem dankbar das ist unfassbar was so
was ausmacht und
das heißt eine familie hat auch einen
großen anteil an dieser medaille und du
hast auch schon deine brüder
angesprochen die beide auch selber sport
betreiben welche motivation löst du
jetzt in den beiden aus für ihre eigenen
sportlichen karriere ja ich habe es die
berge ist zu 100 prozent motiviert vor
dem gehe ich aus und wenn julia bruder
ist immer schon motiviert und wollte
immer schon große
welt kommen aber das problem war bei ihm
leider die verletzungen hin und her
jetzt kämpft er darum dass er wieder
zurückkommt und ich denke
er wieder hier gute zukunft das heißt
möglicherweise gibt es in paris mehr hh
schilder die an den start gehen und dann
hoffentlich auch noch mehr erfolge du
hast mal gesagt dass seine trainerin
imme sagt der olympischen spiele sind
etwas ganz besonderes dass die zum
ersten mal für die spieler qualifiziert
dann gleich so ein traumdebüt hinlegen
hätte man dir das vor zwei drei vier
monaten gesagt dass deine olympischen
spiele so ablaufen werden was hattest du
dazu gesagt ja ich hab schon ehrlich
gesagt seit tag eins daran geglaubt dass
ich teilnehme aber nie von einer
medaille geglaubt schon aber es ist war
einfach nicht leicht vorzustellen und
dann habe ich mehr und mehr als man
glaubt und da glaubt und dann ist es
passiert und man kann es einfach ist
jetzt die zeit nicht so beschreiben ich
brauche noch ein bisschen zeit glaube
ich das war auch die erste medaille seit
lupo paischer in das sportjahr 2008 in
eurosport hat er eine lebende legende
und dass du da jetzt nachfolgt was hat
sich verändert seitdem du die gewissheit
hat dass seitdem die die kämpfe zu ende
gegangen sind das hat sich in seinem
leben bisher in diesen tagen verhindert
nicht viel ich bin noch immer derselbe
schmidt es hat sich nur verändert dass
ich jetzt mehr motivation hat mehr
selbstvertrauen und mit dieser medaille
möchte ich die ganzen jugendliche dazu
motivieren wir haben in österreich
wirklich sehr top sportler die im
trainings sehr sehr stark sind die
leider es auf den abonnieren nicht auf
die matte bringen und ich glaube ich
glaube und ich bin mir sicher mit diesem
medaille sind sie alle jetzt motiviert
sie werden mich jetzt immer im training
sehen und dass wir gemeinsam in paris
dann mehr sind man hat darüber gelesen
dass der gleiche
abend noch hinter dem heimatclub
angerufen hast und seine kolleginnen und
kollegen eben motiviert hast ist du das
auch am herzen das wirklich auch alle
sehen her ist es möglich auch in einem
niemand das zutraut oder vielleicht
niemand einen zettel hat ja ich sehe
mich ja
mit vielen versucht verstärkt zu
telefonieren mit dem ganzen sportler wie
in meiner trainingsgruppe und ja jetzt
mittlerweile haben sie die medaille
schon gesehen und in die hand genommen
und für diese zielsetzung für mich
genauso aber das war einfach so
unvorstellbar weil wir kommen also
österreich
österreichs judo randsportart nicht so
wie in japan russland oder
hohen stellenwert hat und es war schwer
fiel nach dem sportler dran zu glauben
ich habe im training immer versucht die
jüngste motivieren gesagt wir werden das
machen hinter der aber der angezeigt und
jetzt sehen sie dass es geht und jetzt
sind sie umso motivierter und was
glaubst du dass die beiden medaillen im
studio ja auch schon michaela dollar ist
jetzt für seine sportart in österreich
bedeuten was erhoffst du dir durch
diesen auch schon vielleicht wären wir
noch letzte station ist das etwas wovon
träumst ja schon ich hoffe dass jetzt
bald die anleger kurse losgehen und das
jetzt mehr mehr jugendliche mehr kids
ins training kommen und sich viel zu
interessieren das ist eine sehr schöne
sportart sehr komplex man muss im kopf
stark seien physisch man braucht alles
von beweglichkeit koordination alles
möglich und das ist das schöne handschuh
down to go bringt respekt um die ganzen
werte bei die man im leben braucht
kommen wir auch in deinem leben zu den
anfängen wie bist du zum studio sport
gekommen man weiß dass da eine ganze
familie wieder begeistert ist auch deine
cousins sind den leistungszentren und
kämpfen dort wie bist du dazu gekommen
das so sagt er das ist mein sport den
möchte ich machen 2004 sind wieder in
österreich gekommen und meine eltern
wollten unbedingt dass wir irgendeinen
sport machen dass wir uns schnell
integrieren die sprache lernen und neue
freunde kennen lernen ja und dann hat
sich das ergeben durch anklänge kurse in
wels judo und mein erster trainer war
der wille ratzersdorfer wir haben
angefangen und uns hat es spaß gemacht
wir wollten immer mehr mehr mehr dann
hat er uns nachbar wochen dann schon
sofort geschieht wenn ein geschickter
gesagt das kind die mit trainieren und
tag für tag werden es mehr spaß gemacht
und training für training mehr motiviert
und jetzt bin ich hier und dass er noch
sehr erfolgreich aber was hat er denn
genauso spaß gemacht also was war da
bereits zurück sagt dass das tat mir das
möchte ich weiter machen halt messe mit
anna gegner wissen wo bin ich jetzt gut
wo bin ich schlecht kommt das ist das
schöne entscheidung und auch die werte
respekt
dass man was man alles im leben
verbraucht wird im schuber beigebracht
das war das und das ist das schöne in
frage stellt sich das jetzt ein paar
tage
nur leicht trainiert und dann
hoffentlich so weit wie möglich wieder
das harte training aufnimmt was sind die
nächsten ziele jetzt wirklich ganz
nächsten wochen monaten was erwartet
dich jetzt sportlich gesehen aber auch
im drumherum
ich hoffe dass es bald losgeht mit dem
training ich habe jetzt schon
beim sportliche ziele
ich weiß nicht wie es genau weitergeht
ich denke es wird jetzt noch ein
kraftort kommen dass wir im taktischen
bereich noch arbeiten werden und altbau
andere techniken passieren werden dass
wir uns jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
weiterentwickeln und ich denke nächstes
jahr februar paris consline bin ich
wieder weg das in paris den konsum
nächstes jahr angesprochen auch die
olympischen spiele 2000 24 werden dann
in paris stattfinden also ein gutes auf
wer am ende für dich dort aber die
ausgangssituation ist jetzt eine andere
du bist jetzt nicht mehr der underdog
und wenn du als olympia-dritte auf die
matte gehst werden wahrscheinlich auch
deine gegner anders vorbereitet sein
anders auf dich eingestellt sein ist das
jetzt für dich etwas was dich vielleicht
sogar kalkulierbarer macht weil die
gegner deine beine griff besser
studieren werden weil sich das auf dich
einstellen können oder bist du sowieso
so vielfältig und kannst jetzt noch ganz
viel an die arbeiten weil ja noch jung
bist und vor allem im supersport sehr
sehr viele vielfältige dinge noch
trainierbar sind so dass du sagst der
dass das wird mich nicht hindern ich
kann trotzdem auch als linker dritter in
jedem kampf hineingehen und gewinnen ja
ich weiß wirklich nicht wie sich das
anfühlt jetzt mit olympia dritten auf
die matte gehen jetzt bin ich nicht mehr
der handel wieder gesagt hast jetzt bin
ich schon ja weniger favorit
aber ich habe auf alles eine antwort und
ich bin wirklich sehr vielfältig kann
gegen links einfach rechts kämpfer sehr
gut kämpfen und daran werde ich noch
weiterarbeiten ich werde auch die gegner
noch mehr studieren und immer mehr
update was da abgeht von dem ja keine so
gibt es auch jetzt seit einigen jahren
beim bundesheer hast natürlich die
grundausbildung durchlaufen bist als
heeressportler voll im einsatz für
deinen rudersport wie würdest du die
rolle sehen auch viele seiner
kolleginnen und kollegen haben wir zu
erlebte eine medaille gemacht als er das
sportlerinnen und sportler welchen
anteil siehst du da auch vom bundesheer
an so einem erfolg das dann hat er
abgeschlossen und dann musst du
wahrscheinlich entscheiden wie du dich
auf den sport konzentriert also welche
rolle siehst du da bundesheer
sport sehr große rolle ich glaube ohne
bundeswehr wäre ich heute nicht da und
bundesheer hat mir sehr viel
unterstützung
ganz österreich bundes jahr der
österreichischen sporthilfe meine stadt
wels mein verein multikraft wels der
mich alle unterstützt das sei es
finanziell
sei es privat in allen bereichen für das
bin ich unfassbar dankbar und auch
zugleich stolz dass ich die medaille für
österreich holen konnte eine weitere
kollegin von dir die dich sehr
unterstützt hat ist dass sabrina
filzmoser sie hatte ihre karriere jetzt
in tokio in diesem ehrenwerten
stadion beendet aber ihr habt eine ganz
besondere beziehung erzähler mal darüber
sabrina filzmoser ist für mich wie eine
ältere schwester die kenne ich schon
seit
16 jahren wieder mache und er sie hat
uns damals ihre jurist geschenkt und hat
uns immer ins training mitgenommen und
uns unterstützt und versucht uns zu
helfen auf trainingslagern und hin und
her und es war so schön jetzt mit ihr
gemeinsam spielen teilzunehmen
und sie hat ihre karriere beendet und
meine karriere fing der 60 und die kommt
vom selben verein das macht mich extrem
glücklich was es so alles von ihr lernen
können ja vieles vieles ist deshalb
filzmoser ist ein vorbild für viele
junge athleten und ist ja wirklich sehr
sehr gute erfolge
sie ist eine sehr sehr sympathische sehr
sehr gute person sie hat uns wirklich
viel geholfen und die kann man in worten
gar nicht beschreiben dass sie
persönlich jetzt einfach
unwahrscheinlich und da sieht man auch
welchen einfluss sie nicht noch nicht
gehabt hat sondern wahrscheinlich auch
noch viele andere menschen auch hier
findest du dich in dieser rolle wieder
dass du als erfolgreicher athlet für
andere diese vorbildwirkung haben kannst
nicht wissen oder sagst das möchte ich
möchte damit junge sportlerinnen und
sportler motivieren oder ist es gar
nicht etwas was du aktiv annehmen möchte
ich habe davon geträumt und dies ist es
zum glück war geworden und das ist mein
ziel ich will die jungen dazu motivieren
dass sie
glauben dass sie groß denken und dass
sie hart an sich arbeiten das in
österreich alles möglich ist
egal in welcher sportart das spielt
keine rolle ob man das wieder macht oder
eine andere sportart
wohl den er nun beweisen dass
österreich in allem unterstützt und ich
hoffe und ich bin mir sicher dass jetzt
viele sportler gas geben werden und
viele sportler jetzt sportlich aktiv
sehr in den österreich und damit kannst
du auf jeden fall dein ziel erreichen in
einem interview gesagt dass deine
schwäche ist dass du schnell dann auch
überheblich wirst du und gegen leute
verliert gegen die eigentlich nicht
verlieren solltest was tust du damit
dass jetzt sportlich gesehen in den
kämpfen wie du hineingehe ist eben nicht
passiert nachdem wir jetzt den größten
erfolg seiner bisherigen karriere
gefeiert hast ja ich werde den weg
fortsetzen jetzt wie möglich spielen
wieder taktisch auf jeden ein
eingestellt sein und
versuchen es gut möglich umzusetzen ich
habe sehr viele fehler gemacht auf den
wir jetzt hinauf aber ich habe immer
daraus gelernt und das war das
wichtigste was ja auch lange verletzte
vor den spielen das steckt man sich in
solchen phasen in denen man vielleicht
nicht so trainieren kann wie man
eigentlich möchte wo man vielleicht auch
zweifel hat wo man sich überlegt man wie
mache ich überhaupt weiter wie es ist in
solchen momenten gegangen ich hatte zum
glück noch gerne große verletzung die
größte verletzungen am handgelenk da hat
da musste ich sechs wochen pausieren ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen das hat mir
wirklich sehr viel geholfen und ich habe
wirklich viel trainiert und einen
sportwissenschaftler gregor bialas und
eine judo trainer haben gesagt du musst
mal pause machen weniger ist mehr
manchmal und ich habe gesagt nein ich
will mehr und mehr an ich will da noch
stärker werde ich mich körperlich
stärker sein und ich möchte kollektiv
stark gesehen dann kam die verletzung
und das hat mir wirklich geholfen ich
konnte nicht mehr weitermachen und dann
nach sechs wochen wie ich zurückgekommen
bin konnte ich gar nicht von der seite
herunter gehen das war einfach ja
manchmal einfach viel mehr motiviert da
siehst du auch
aus dieser lebenserfahrung heraus dass
es manchmal auch schwierige umstände
dann etwas gutem führen können ist auch
etwas was dir in seiner mentalen stärke
hilft extrem extrem man muss immer
versuchen dass man das positive
herausnehmen und wie gesagt ich hoffe
nicht dass ich jetzt große verletzungen
gekommen aber solche verletzungen haben
wir schon geholfen da bist du mental
stärker da hast du dann zeit an deine
schwächen zu arbeiten an sachen zu
arbeiten was du noch mal nicht macht wie
zum beispiel video analysen oder
kraftübungen wo du keine zeit hat ist
das dann genug zeit daran zu arbeiten
und da kommst stärker zurück in solchen
momenten ist dann auch die familie ein
wichtiger faktor für dich man weißt du
hast eben zwei brüder fünf schwestern
ihr seid also acht geschwister ist das
ein ankerpunkt für dich dass du dich
auch dort mit genug kraft sozusagen
ernähren kannst du in deiner familie und
meine familie unterstützt mich in allem
es ist sehr schön bei uns zu hause
nehmen eine kleine schwester und mit ihr
verbringen wir sehr viel zeit wenn wir
nachts vom training nach hause kommen
oder wie man fertig sind
spazieren wir mit ihr und lacht mit hier
macht ja nie unterstützt mich sehr gut
was hat eine ganze scheiße gesagt hat
wie realisiert hat dass du jetzt da die
mauerteile gewonnen hat hat jetzt
überhaupt richtig realisieren können ja
ja sie
haben wir gleich angerufen im
olympischen dorf und gesagt wahnsinn ich
liebe dich und jena und das hat ja wie
viel gibt ja dass salzburg liefering
weiß das sind sehr viele sehr viel das
ist unbeschreiblich und das ist erst der
erste große erfolg jetzt bei uns in der
familie und ich habe noch zwei brüder in
sachen klima und ich bin mir sicher dass
wir sehr gute zukunft haben werden ich
habe es auf jeden fall also noch einiges
vor paris hast du ja schon als ziel
ausgegeben in ausbildung schon
angesprochen dass die maschinenbauer
hatte erfolgreich abgeschlossen wenn du
ganz so weit in die zukunft schauen wo
siehst du dein leben welchem weg sie ist
in deinem leben noch sich weiter
fortführen bleibt es für immer der
judosport du wirst du dann trainer
werden wirst du dann sportdirektor
werden oder doch noch andere dinge vor
im leben
schwierig schwierig sehr schwierig ich
wollte anfangs mit meiner ausbildung
wollte ich nicht ins berufsleben
einsteigen und arbeiten und dann hat
dieses ergeben dass ich jetzt sport
mache viele drehen habe ich motiviert
angesagt sein tor so viel potenzial und
die musste position ausnutzen und das
machen
100er und so ja und dann dank bundesheer
und dann den anderen sponsoren und der
stadt wels der mich toll unterstützt und
da habe ich gesagt okay ich mache das
ich probiere das mal und es hat sich
wirklich ausgezahlt und ich bin dankbar
für jede einzelne person die mich da
unterstützt und das auch vorher gesagt
du bist auch österreich natürlich sehr
dankbar du hast kurz angeschnitten wie
ihr 2004 nach österreich gekommen dass
du jetzt dort stehst die österreichische
flagge geht hoch welche gedanken gehen
einem da durch den kopf bei seiner
siegerehrung wenn man dort steht ich
habe mich wirklich zusammenreißen dass
ich nicht jetzt der unfall war einfach
unglaubliches gefühl
wir sind 2004 machen wie es gekommen ist
bester raich hat mir soviel gegeben ich
konnte hier in österreich
ist ja gut der ausbildung abschließen
ich habe die htl maschine
bauingenieurswesen abgeschlossen danach
haben sie mich unterstützt im sport aus
dem sportlichen weg bundesheer stadt
wels wie ich jetzt gesagt habe und die
sponsoren an die ganzen trainings es
ihnen einfach so viele menschen die
wieder unterstützt haben und
mich so stolz gemacht ja das ist
unbeschreiblich was österreich mit
jemand und ich versuche jetzt das so gut
wie möglich zu geben und das ist auf
jeden fall nicht nur durch deinen stolz
sondern auch durch die sportlichen
erfolge und durch die botschaften jetzt
auch schon immer wieder anklingen hast
lassen auch am anfang im endeffekt den
sport als möglichkeit zur erfolgreichen
integration um jetzt über die erfolge
andere kinder und jugendliche zu
motivieren herzlichen dank auf jeden
fall für deinen einsatz für deine
einstellung und reputation noch einmal
zu den sportlichen erfolgen wir hoffen
natürlich dass das nicht die letzten
geblieben sein werden und wir noch von
dir sehr viel höheren werden alles gute
auf jeden fall ein gedanke ja das war es
vom sportart herzlichen dank dass ihr
auch dieses mal mit dabei war und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]